depuis juin 2021 sayyed travail dans
cette ressourcerie à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ici ils
récupèrent des appareils électriques les
nettoie et les revend une activité bien
loin de son métier d'origine sayyed est
afghan à kaboul il était journaliste
pigiste pour plusieurs télévisions
locales il a aussi travaillé avec la
croix-rouge d'afghanistan était une
forme de commentaires mais diop a blessé
tu es j'ai fait un montage aussi mais
quand je suis allé à notre village par
le faire à lever diot par le
documentaire de tous les mondes
téléphone avec le camra ce n'était pas
possible parce que le talmud c'est le
tellement vu ça
problème pour moi on décembre 2018 il
retourne dans la province de nimroz dans
le sud ouest de l'afghanistan là où les
talibans ils font leur loi il est alors
accusée d'espionnage le début des
problèmes pour sayed espions pas
travailler pour les autres pays donc je
dis non c'est pas vrai alors cassé mon
caméra téléphone après cette altercation
sayed repart à kaboul mais les menaces
de mort continue il est désormais dans
le viseur des talibans le 10 février
2019 il tente même de le kidnapper en
pleine rue sont nés trop pour sayed le
12 février ils quittent l'afghanistan en
laissant sa femme et ses deux enfants
j'ai fait beaucoup d'argent pour auxerre
et doivent dans un accident après iron
après top après le torque
plusieurs pieds d'europe après j'arrive
en
jarez un mois de mars mars 2010neuf
j'arrive en allemand après elle m'a mis
dans le centre aux gens ce réfugié
on sent que cinq mois après cinq ans il
m'a dit ok tout cas les autres vous ça y
est choisit donc la france un long
périple administratif des buts il dort
sous une tente porte de la chapelle à
paris deux mois plus tard il rejoint le
centre d'hébergement d'urgence de bonnel
il obtient alors le statut de réfugié en
décembre 2020 à 33 ans sayyed attend
maintenant que sa famille obtienne un
visa pour venir en france cachée elle
est toujours menacé de mort à kaboul